hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
22nd of July today and you're tuned into
games but years first up eat the story
about Crash Bandicoot but i'll let you
enjoy a few more blissful seconds apart
before I tell you it's also a story
about naughty dog saying it's probably
not the right time for crash there's a
sliver of hope though as the dev have
said it's never off the table community
strategist on Maya said it's not too
much time passing but it's the same
issues we explored with the jak and
daxter game is it something that makes
sense to us now I mean we still have
people to worked on the crash games in
the studio we never forget our past and
it would be great for nostalgic reasons
it would be the same reason as why there
isn't a jak 4 I don't know if it's
playing to our strengths right now
previously mentioned jak and daxter game
which was being worked on by the last of
us direct at Neil druckmann never quite
made it out because Naughty Dog didn't
think that the game they were making was
true to the series Maya continued to
express that right now the studio is
mostly interested in narrative driven
games with strong characters speaking of
Neil druckmann gamers were a little
upset when Sony said they wouldn't be
offering any deals for owners of the ps3
version of The Last of Us eyeing off the
ps4 remastered version likely gamestop
has come to the rescue starting on the
twenty-seventh of July you can pop by
your local gamestop trade in your
original ps3 copy of the Last of Us and
get a sweet fifty percent off the
remastered version for ps4 it's a pretty
good deal but it also ends on August
second so if you're tossing up whether
you watch your clicker riddled
apocalypse remastered now is the time to
decide next up to massive delays have
come down the pipeline today the first
being for battlefield hardline the cops
and robbers focused shooter needs more
time to ferment and be refined according
to Battlefield series creator dice the
plan is to give devs time to add new
community-driven feature ideas to the
multiplayer experience and polish up the
story experience within the single
player dies of also said they're super
aware of not wanting a repeat of
battlefield 4's janky launch and they
believe the extra time will enable them
to ensure that hard line is far more
no new release date has been announced
so far next up on the delay train is
dragon age inquisition so between this
and the battlefield hardline news we
should have effectively brought
disappointment on the majority of
today's news viewers ea's other game is
being pushed back again to November 18
of this year more than a month later
than its original October 7 release date
but hey the game's first delay was a
year long so it could be much worse
executive producer mock Dara has said
the team needs time to nuke bugs and
polish the overall experience he says
that they are ensuring that our open
spaces are as engaging as possible
strengthening the emotional impact of
the heroes choices and ensuring the
experience you get is the best it can be
in the platform you choose to play on
next up I'm gonna talk about dota 2 and
which dota 2 team won the big
tournaments that was on this year so if
you don't want to know the results he
can switch off now I won't mind said big
dota 2 tournament was the international
floor which was offering up almost 11
million bucks in prize money thanks to
community contributions the recipients
of half that giant stack of cash our
Chinese team you be who beat out fellow
countryman vici gaming by winning three
consecutive games after losing their
first in the grand finals but vici
gaming still earn themselves just under
1.5 million and North America's evil
geniuses team grabs just over 1 million
making them some of the highest earning
players ever might be a good time to get
into eSports and I'll see you a question
of the day let me know down in that
comment box which game you reckon you
could be best in the world at if you had
to choose if you like conventions and
live stream goodness and it's well worth
you knowing that San Diego comic-con is
a thing that's happening this week we
will be having a to our lab sure from
Thursday through to saturday starting at
4pm PT each day so visit gamespot to get
stuck into that for all the info and
whatnot those are all the new things I
wanted to tell you about today but
tomorrow I'll have more bits and pieces
so be sure to join me again then